some sad news uh coming into us this  evening the u.s actress anne hesh has  died just over a week since she was  injured in a car crash and her family  and friends have just released a  statement saying we have lost a bright  light a kind and most joyful soul a  loving mother and a loyal friend anne  will be deeply missed but she lives on  through her beautiful sons her iconic  body of work and her passionate advocacy  her bravery for always standing in her  truth spreading her message of love and  acceptance will continue to have a  lasting impact a statement there  released on behalf of the family and  friends of ann hesh the  actress who died as a result of a car  accident a week ago